on this episode I talk about my course
in college snowball fights and how you
become viral with no cash you ask
questions and I answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
what's up everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and you're watching the
askgaryvee show episode number 63 it is
snowing insane outside and it hasn't
even started
Blizzard 2015 is here and the weather
has completely screwed up my Tuesday as
you can imagine so I'm gonna sneak this
in real quick and answer one or two
questions today so a tight show for
episode 63 but that's the way it is
Chris asks what surprises or interest
you about brands with high brand equity
but don't have huge budget Chris this is
a great question I also love the
Instagram photo this whole Instagram
thing is gonna be awesome as in fact you
know what I almost didn't do this
episode so do Drock I know you're
disappointed with only two questions but
that's better than zero and you've heard
that before you like that like that's
the fun so um so that actually gives me
a second here to push the vaynernation
because I know we went out super late
the other night Instagram photos
Instagram questions let's link up how
you do that
let's get on that for the rest of the
week chris is a great question you know
look this is why I love social media I
believe that social media is the
plumbing to word-of-mouth in our society
and I think there's a lot of brands that
don't spend marketing that just win on
having a great product if you make a
great product and you get people to
taste it physically and literally
meaning try your app you know check out
your store wear your hoodie or actually
try sauce and it's delicious
word-of-mouth will kick in I think the
world we live in now it actually speeds
that up because when somebody had that
sauce now they take a photo and put an
Instagram be like this is delicious
that's a lot better than 1997 we're like
I have this sauce and then like Stefan
and I were playing basketball I go by
the way this sauce like what I did that
one slick like it was impossible to
amplify the way we are now on an
individual person level so I actually
think the era of companies with very
limited or zero marketing budgets is
here and I do think social media is that
foundation so what interests me is that
this is the greatest time ever to not
have a marketing budget
as a marketer because so much of it can
be organic and authentic it's hard you
have to be great and most of all your
product has to be sensational so I think
the brands that will break out the
products that will break out in the next
half decade with zero dollars are gonna
be anomalies but that's predicated on
them actually making a phenomenal
product blue Archer asked if you could
create or teach your own college or high
school course what would the name of the
class be and how would you teach it this
is a great question first of all this is
really fun like I thought all the
Instagram photos were just going to be
somebody holding up a sign like the
rules
I didn't realize so many people you like
that'll jab on the rules I do by the way
vaynernation you're not following the
rule it's like the whole like sign thing
is not happening but let's do it over
time here's how you get your answer but
obviously because some of you are
getting through with your non following
the rules answers you guys are all gonna
continue to do this but the whole like
imposing me into the photo is phenomenal
didn't see that coming good job if you
guys ah my course would be called oh my
god this is such a funny thing I mean my
course would literally be called why you
shouldn't have signed up for this course
in the first place taught by Gary
Vaynerchuk and it would talk about the
disconnect between where school is and
world the real world is right now how I
would try to teach more than anything
for people not to take my words and try
to regurgitate them look it's almost
what I'm trying to mean I'm teaching my
course right now with askgaryvee my big
thing here guys is and I and I razz the
vaynernation once in a while so in this
short episode it feels appropriate way
to many of you are just regurgitating
what I'm saying instead of actually
doing it boy do I love all of you that
hard it up my hustle picture on
Instagram the other day let's put that
up and then when I looked at like seven
or eight people to just see how they
were hustling cuz I keep doing it I keep
internation understand one thing I take
enormous pride and double checking your
actions while you regurgitate my
hyperbole let me tell you why
I'm the best dude ever it's because if
my fans that spew my stuff aren't
actually acting on my recommendation
which is putting in the work doing the
right things
listening to their audience working
hustling trying doing the right
practices not automating well then when
people like if you post a photo on
regram it and like hustle but you're
playing you know called duty of duty all
day then that all your friends on
instagram the 97 people like well that's
just a guy that spews hyperbole because
if you love him so much but you aren't
doing it well then that just disconnects
so one of the main reasons I'm paying
attention to what everybody's doing is
because if the people that are consuming
my content and retweeting and pushing
out my stuff are not acting on that
behavior that has a chance of hurting me
you know fun it's been over the last
four or five months because of this show
because of the zinging that you many of
the people that have commented on every
episode have emailed me and said you
know what I haven't actually been doing
it like I'm talking the talk but I'm not
walking the walk that's been really fun
for me to watch and so I forgot the
question oh it's the course right I mean
look the course would be like listen to
everything I'm gonna tell you about the
disconnect between school and the real
world from a marketing business
standpoint I know you could be a lawyer
or doctor you need to learn that stuff I
respect that but from like entrepreneur
business stuff and the whole course
would be eight to 12 weeks of me
pounding you not to regurgitate my
information but to act on it over here
I'm over here now d-roc you need to act
on it you need to actually execute you
can't say hustle and then not hustle you
can't say and this is the the hustle
part a lot of you are doing here's the
part that really pisses me off all of
you that retweeted my whole listen to
people instead of just talk you think
gage wait and the other thing is a lot
of you are engaging with each other
which is great I love that like twenty
of you have become really good friends
and retweet each other and hard
everything but go out there new search
on Twitter right try different things go
right meet our articles on medium I
can't believe how many of them you are
not writing
articles on medium the one platform that
rewards virality to people that have no
audience the far majority of you you
should be what we're hustling medium
every day and I have awareness because
it's giving me more free awareness guys
medium is a platform that allows you if
you write a good story for one of their
editors to put on the homepage and all
of a sudden you've got a platform and a
couple of you've done it and we pounded
it here and you've seen me doing it
that's the part that pisses me off if
you see me doing it heavy plenty of new
Basti hey askgaryvee why do you post up
on medium and not your own blog because
it brings me just so everybody
understands I will never do anything if
it doesn't bring me either short-term or
long-term value so if I'm doing it don't
you think you should be paying attention
a little more about why and so my course
would be very proud bringing you back my
course will be very predicated on here's
all the advice but please don't be a
student be a practitioner question of
the day I want to hear the story of your
favorite all-time snow day mine me and
my sister we're having a small snowball
fight and we literally got into a rhythm
we had both have like little bunkers I'd
throw it she'd duck she throw it I
ducked and then about four or five in I
figured out the timing so I made two and
I threw one but then I got really ready
again and as soon as she came up I threw
it and hit her directly in the mouth and
she bled all over the place and AJ
thought it was funny cuz he was only
three you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering on this episode I talk
about